i am a big fan of the series
really enjoyed this uh final season of
narcos mexico i just finished it
yesterday she want to say congrats on it
thank you so much
um so myra i just have to start with you
and just a quick question um how much
fun is it playing like a ruthless badass
i love it i love it because sometimes
you know they teach us to be a nice
woman in this world and you have to be
nice and you have to be polite
and then you have this role that you can
be that tough
woman you can be the one that can say i
want this and we're gonna do it and the
woman that wants to fall in love so
i got everything with anything now
a hundred percent um
as a fan of the series and talking like
like sort of representing fans what do
you guys think um people would be
surprised to learn about the making of
the series like the behind the scenes of
what's what it's like when you're trying
to film it
when i got into this nargos world it was
um you know i i used to watch the show
before and uh i mean it's so great
you actually you know
behind the scenes you actually never
expect something less than you see on
the show you know on netflix when it's
already streaming so
i don't know i think the most exciting
part of it is
the
the fires and uh you know the guns
shooting and you know when i was on set
i i had to share you know this uh set
with uh
with the sequence that i'm not gonna
talk about because i won't do spoilers
but uh but it was exciting because you
know i was i was doing a whole other
thing
and uh then all of a sudden i would i
would hear shots you know so it was like
it's so funny because i you know i kind
of like forgot i i was not aware if it
was true or not
and i was not
acquainted to the sound of a gunshot so
i was like
you know so it was funny but yeah i mean
uh behind the scenes is just great and
uh i don't know it's just that
i want to keep it secret for the fans
and the audience to really see that so
for me was um
you know when you see narcos it's like
it's a huge show so i thought
before i i was there and and was part of
the cast i thought they were
very serious persons you know that they
were kind of
you know
formal and
but no then you get to the set and all
of them are so fun and so gentle and
people make jokes about
life and about us and about everything
so it's kind of
weird that we're talking about
a very violent you know
thing and behind the scenes we're having
a lot of fun
a lot
i've heard that from some of the other
actors um i am curious do you guys after
making this series do you have a
different perspective on the drug war
like because i personally have a
completely different perspective on it
after watching all the seasons of narcos
and i'm just curious if it's affected
you guys in any way
yes for me yes i mean
i'm so sad that we cannot get enough of
power
you know i am a powerful person but i
want more and more and more it's like
when we will have enough
and it's you know it's a uh
something very big that
how can we handle it because there's
people the people wants drugs
so
no one is safe in this
violent game you know
it
yeah
you know i am part of the other side of
the story you know i'm a good guy here
right so
um
you know the truth matters so much to
andrea and uh
she
finds out that as she imagined it was a
very dangerous world and a very obscure
world and that it was ruled by men and
you know it's uh
it didn't change my perspective on on
narco you know
talking about narco because i never
agreed with it right
but as playing as one of the good guys
it's like i can sustain my idea about um
drugs and stuff you know and uh
you know it's it's
my ambition to go for the truth goes so
far you know that that things
might happen to me you know and i'm kind
of like as a woman and as a young
women's young journalists i'm not
measuring the danger and
it's like
you know i really i really really want
to know the truth and i and i won't stop
until i have it you know it it won't
matter
what happens right even if it happens
something to me or
to to to the newspaper or whatever right
so um
yeah truth truth
for both of you um i would imagine that
you getting ready for these roles you
did some research i'm imagining you
tried to go further than what's in the
script to try to help you prepare for
these roles was there anything that you
learned about the time and the people
and uh the era that you were really
surprised by and like you know um sort
of took took it with you
i love your question because it makes me
think about my
mom
you know um
i was like i was very young
in the 80s in the 90s i was very young
and and i didn't realize
um
how all my mom weren't through you know
she worked very hard and she was trying
to be someone and she was trying to
you know to work and work and work and
and and
and then with this show i understood
like
it's pretty hard it's pretty hard to get
where you want to get it's pretty hard
to get your dreams come true it's pretty
hard to be someone
and that someone listens to you
um
i know we're talking about drugs
but it's pretty hard everything that you
really want here in your heart and you
don't understand because people want
something about you and maybe you don't
want that
and you have to be what
someone else's want
so i don't know it's kind of
for me
i don't i
i'm very confused about ourselves as
human beings you know
like i don't understand
why we push
all of us
in ideas that they are not
personal ideas you know or or dreams or
something like that
so i i
yeah with narcos and and all
their world
it's like they really want that
how they become
that kind of narco
because they could be another kind of
narco and they could they could but why
why they choose that kind of way the
violent way
why
and there's a reason and and that's what
make me you know think about
all this show
i was born in in the night in 1998 i'm
23 years old and my parents were not
even here you know um they're from
argentina so four injures you know here
in mexico so i had to do a lot of
research right and
the thing that surprised me the more you
know is that in 94 you really found
really strong women around you know and
and of course i had to do a lot of
research in uh journalism you know and
journalists female journalists and i'm
talking about um
uh annabelle hernandez i'm talking about
navarro you know those are kind of like
the
figures that i followed uh in the
building of of of andrea you know in
making
and uh yeah
when i was doing the research i was
really surprised about um the bravery of
those of this woman and of course that i
got some stuff you know out of them
and i put them in andrea for sure you
know so
yeah women it never they never cease to
amaze me so
i agree on that note thank you for your
time um seriously congrats on the season
have a great day
thank you so much
you